here with reaction he's from the Trump
organization he's involved in this case
it is a National Disgrace Eric Trump
glad to have you back sir
it's great to be on Sean I you know I
don't even know where to begin I'm
giving minor examples of tiny little
properties going for 200 250 million in
Palm Beach I'm talking about dirt going
for 150 million you have 20 some odd
Acres an iconic property intercoastal
ocean how is it possible this judge can
do the very thing that they are accusing
you your brother and your father of
doing
because Sean they don't care they don't
care about the details smartlog is one
of the most valuable properties anywhere
in the world worth well over a billion
dollars look at the portfolio of
properties they're incredible and
there's no one that's done more for the
New York City skyline than Donald Trump
we hire literally and employ thousands
and thousands of workers but those
details don't matter to these monsters
you know why because these monsters want
to have my father in a courthouse they
want to have my father spend tens and
tens and tens of millions of dollars so
he's distracted so he can't be in South
Carolina and he can't be in Iowa and he
can't be in Nevada he can't be
prosecuting Joe Biden for being the
worst president in the history of this
country and you know what these people
won't bring up the fact that we have
unbelievable relationships with our
banks every single one of our banks has
made hundreds of millions of dollars on
our organization we've never been in
default we've never missed a payment
we've never gotten a nasty letter we've
got great relationships with all of them
we've done an unbelievable job in
coincidentally there's only two assets
that we've actually ever sold with which
both went for hundreds of millions of
dollars more than my father had them
listed for in the statement of financial
condition and then I get to walk into
court and see records where Mar-A-Lago
is listed at 18 million dollars it's a
joke I literally sit there and I say
which tennis court Sean you know but
again that's not why the Attorney
General is doing this I remember when
she was running for attorney general in
2018 and she literally starts coming out
her whole platform that she raised money
on was I'm gonna go after Donald Trump
I'm gonna get him I'm gonna get his
family I'm gonna force him out of New
York
you know and it's it's a travesty when
you see the amount of buildings my
father has built he has redefined the
skyline of New York City we employ
thousands of people and these aren't
Executives these are you know Maids
these are Engineers these are security
officers and they come in there and say
I want to take away all of his business
licenses because we don't like the man
we try and embarrass him during a
presidential year it's election
interference it's disgusting New York
has the worst problems of any City
arguably in the country it's dirty it's
crime ridden you've got illegal
immigration problems all over the place
and this is what the Attorney General
spends her time on going after a guy who
has put more money and more assets and
done more to shape an amazing American
city that Donald Trump all because he's
a political adversary it's disgusting
and to bring the family into it who had
nothing to do with any of this I mean
Sean this should be illegal in the
United States of America this is what
they do in communist Russia this is what
they do in Venezuela you know and it
shouldn't happen and believe me and I've
said this Chief before it's all coming
from the top Sean it's all coming from
Joe Biden because they want to take out
the guy who is otherwise going to beat
him in 2024. this is why I want the
Judiciary Committee is doing this is
under Jim Jordan they're investigating
whether our FBI and doj at the top not
Rank and file have been weaponized and
politicized this is the weaponization of
justice and this is now going to go on
you know it's now October a year from
now we'll be on the verge of a
presidential election and they want to
put your dad basically the entire year
in a courtroom you know in in venues
where I can almost assure you Eric I
don't want to give you news you don't
want to hear you already know your dad
can't get a fair trial in New York he's
not going to get a fair trial in D.C or
Fulton County Georgia for that matter so
it's okay we'll have you know what Sean
I I give the judge I I give I give the
judge this afternoon credit I really do
in the last five minutes you really you
know he pretty much said he came out and
said pretty clearly that many of the
cases or many of the claims are knocked
out because they fell well before the
statute of limit limitation so I give
the guy a lot of credit in trying to do
the right thing
people are understanding exactly five
Eric a five minute Google search would
have shown him that his valuation of
Mar-A-Lago was asinine
you don't have to be a genius Eric
I agree I listen uh Sean there's no
question if I'm in Google search wood
and you know to look at mar-a-lagos
being valued at 18 million dollars
there's a joke in fact everyone I'll buy
it in Florida or 18 million I'll buy it
and sell it and make hundreds of
millions I'll be able to retire and be
like hitting the lotto and I'm not
joking about it because it's not funny
um I'm sorry you're going through this
this is wrong you know you we can have
attorney generals targeting people in
campaigns and then doing it in court
this is not Justice in America that is
not constitutional law in America uh
please update us on this location it's
day one Sean they did it since day one
since a minute my father came down that
escalator they went after him the
Washington Post literally 10 minutes
after he got the call from Hillary
Clinton when she conceded the Washington
Post said this is when the impeachment
of Donald Trump begins you're right and
they have never stopped between the
impeachments and between Kavanaugh and
perfect phone calls you know they're the
Russia hoax the hell that they've put
our family through and when they
realized they couldn't do it at the
executive branch guess what they moved
to State AGS and district attorneys in
the most far left Democratic areas in
the entire country to do what they fail
to do in Washington D.C and it's a hell
our family lives every day and I am so
thankful I've got the toughest father in
the world to fight this crap for what it
is and you know what Sean he's going to
win I mean he's going to win I'm telling
you people understand the Sham for what
I hope you're right Eric because the
every the deck stacked against them I
mean they're throwing everything they
got at them uh I don't know how he's
still standing I don't know how all of
you are still standing
really corrupt and wrong we're losing
the country that's all there is to it
this is not just it doesn't win we will
not have a country because this one and
these other Republicans they'll never be
able to carry the weight that my
father's carried never they don't have
the backbone they don't have the
willpower they don't have the voice they
certainly don't have that I don't even
know why it bothers I mean at some point
you got to say I gotta you know I don't
know Eric good to see you I'm sorry you
don't go through this hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else